so the more we learn about Ron
desantis's Martha's Vineyard immigrant
stunt the more we realize it was
certainly immoral it was certainly
unethical it was certainly a waste of
Florida taxpayer money to send
immigrants that were in Texas to an
island off the coast of Massachusetts
those things we all know we know that it
was dishonest because we have now
learned that the immigrants were indeed
enticed with false promises of all sorts
of goodies at the end of the rainbow for
lack of a better term but now there's a
new question and as often is the case
with the very people who claim that they
are all about law enforcement and due
process and doing everything correctly
in Law and Order or Line Auto as Donald
Trump has said before it may not have
been legal either and there is a very
very good article in NPR about this on
npr.org by Valerie Crowder and I'm going
to tell you some of the key points here
that are now in question about whether
this was Lee legal or could it have been
illegal human trafficking so the first
aspect to this is that Ron DeSantis
described the flights on which the
immigrants were taken to Martha's
Vineyard as voluntary when he was
speaking at a press conference on Friday
it appears that that was a lie
immigration law experts say that
actually what happened was the
trafficking of migrants when you lie to
people to induce them to come somewhere
to the U.S or whatever in order for
something that is not true you are
participating in what is functionally
speaking the same type of trafficking
where young girls are tricked into going
wherever with the promises of whatever
it is they're promised and then they're
actually forced into prostitution as an
example the dynamic is exactly the same
and we've now learned that these
immigrants were told you're going to be
flown to Boston they weren't they were
flown to Martha's Vineyard you'll get
expedited work papers which was not
actually what was waiting for them in
Martha's Vineyard and instead what
happened was churches and shelters and
Aid groups as NPR rights
did the best to accommodate them on an
island with an extraordinarily low
population and very limited resources
now then we heard from a
tallahassee-based immigration attorney
Elizabeth Ricci also quoted in this NPR
article who says there is a good faith
argument to be made
that when you lure migrants onto planes
with false promises of jobs you are
making them victims of fraudulent human
trafficking
think of that that is what the governor
of Florida has potentially engaged in
here they were told oh you might uh
you're going to get this you're going to
get that now here's the unbelievable
part
if indeed these individuals are
determined to have been the victims of
Fraud and human trafficking they could
automatically qualify for visas here in
the United States what Ron DeSantis may
have illegally done could we don't know
yet actually genuinely expedite these
individuals to legal status here in the
United States Richie explained quote an
enticement like that regardless of
whether you sign a waiver is fraud and
that's part of the definition of human
trafficking I think that everybody on
those planes has a case to legalize as a
direct result of being transported by
the governor Republicans will do illegal
things
and if they get arrested or prosecuted
they will claim they are merely
political prisoners that they're being
treated unfairly this is what happened
after the January 6 riots the January
6th rioters and there were hundreds of
them I think the numbers up to seven or
eight hundred although it may even be
over a thousand they were
um uh acting criminally
and then once the law caught up with
them uh these the claims started to be
made of well they're they're not being
given the right food in jail they're
being held unfairly in jail pre-trial
detention is unfair these are victims of
politics they're being punished because
of their opinion about an election this
is the move so without a doubt if the
law starts to catch up to DeSantis and
whoever else for this absurd stunt
mark my words and you know this I don't
have to convince you of this they will
claim they are actually the victims the
people who did this who were just trying
to prove a point now one other thing
there are right Wingers who think
they're being really slick by saying
something like the following and there's
versions of this floating around you
know
all you Northern liberals talk about
Texas and Florida and Arizona should
just accept hundreds of thousands of
migrants and it's very easy to say from
Vermont or from Massachusetts or
whatever but as soon as 50 people get to
Martha's Vineyard they are immediately
deported out
multiple things going on here first of
all it's not a deportation when you're
just flown from one state to another
that's number one number two the intent
of these immigrants was not to be in
Martha's Vineyard Martha's Vineyard is
Tiny there's very few jobs it's a very
small economy and it's a very seasonal
economy because of Tourism and we're
heading into fall and then winter which
is low season in Martha's Vineyard
there's not the real opportunity
for any jobs there there's
extraordinarily limited housing Etc so
there's really not the hypocrisy that
the right wants to point out furthermore
they were lied to
in so getting to Martha's Vineyard and
as I mentioned it was not their intent
so this this hypocrisy that the right is
trying to expose in talking about the
Martha's Vineyard thing it's a joke and
we shouldn't allow them to turn that
around because it just doesn't make any
sense whatsoever one of our longtime
sponsors is monk pack offering low sugar
plant-based keto-friendly bars I love
these they are the perfect snack for
anyone trying to eat better or cutting
back on sugar and carbs without
sacrificing taste monk pack offers
granola bars and nut and Seed bars each
with only one gram of sugar or less two
to three net carbs and 150 calories or
less I'm a big fan of the macadamia
white chocolate nut and Seed bar great
combination of sweet salty chewy and
crunchy and there's under one gram of
sugar they come in other awesome flavors
like sea salt dark chocolate coconut
coconut cocoa chip and caramel sea salt
monk pack is great if you're doing keto
I don't do keto but monk pack is just
great for anyone who wants something
delicious On The Go without the sugar
and my audience gets 20 off your first
order at monkpak.com when you use the
coupon code Pacman at checkout the link
is down below